dire je voudrais quand même signaler
aussi et je pense que ça posera sa
monnaie a posé une question d'acteurs
tordjman puisque il est auteur de livres
qu'il existe aujourd'hui toute une
littérature en dehors donc du circuit
scolaire qui permet soit aux familles
soit même aux enfants mais il faudrait
voir s'il n'y a pas là aussi des risques
de s'informer en dehors et de la famille
et du circuit scolaire dans le bar dans
un reportage de d'alain gillot pétré
on trouve de tout dans un grand magasin
au rayon librairie une majorité de
succès du jour beaucoup de livres
érotiques et curieusement une forte
proportion d'ouvragé éducation sexuelle
pour les enfants c'est un genre qui se
vend bien qui se vend mieux même que la
littérature pornographique
il est vrai que pour cette dernière les
magasins de sexe ne manquent pas ce sont
les parents qui achètent le plus souvent
les livres pour eux mêmes ou leurs
enfants et surtout l'encyclopédie de la
vie sexuelle chez hachette cinq volumes
qui vont de 7 ans à l'âge adulte de 7 à
9 ans point de photos des dessins on en
est encore à raconter une histoire vous
faire des comparaisons avec la
reproduction des animaux ou des fleurs
mais le vocabulaire est vrai un
testicule est un testicule
même si un spermatozoïde est un petit
état cependant l'idée de plaisir n'est
qu évoqué au profit d'une description
complète de la fécondation de la
grossesse de la naissance on n'est plus
dans les choux les cigognes ont été
plumés
pour les 10 13 ans la photo est la règle
on entre dans l'explication scientifique
des phénomènes sexuelle les acteurs de
l'histoire car il s'agit encore d'un
récit ont évidemment l'âge de leurs
lecteurs tout en augmentant le volume
des mots qui décrivent ce sujet jeudi ce
tabou les auteurs abordent également les
problèmes de la contraception et l'on
découvre au fil des photos comme une
représentation de la tendresse
or les 14 16 ans plus l'histoire ni le
mise en scène mais des questions souvent
très direct on est dans le monde de
l'infiniment petit avec une description
minutieuse des différentes étapes d'une
grossesse de même les questions
psychologiques prennent le pas sur les
questions physiologique
à la limite les rapports entre les êtres
affectivement socialement
fraternellement ont plus d'importance
que les rapports sexuels propre monde
enfin pour les adolescents réalité et
problèmes de la vie sexuelle du docteur
tordjman est un ouvrage de vérité
[Musique]
les titres des chapitres démontre à
l'évidence la volonté d'être clair franc
et exhaustif on n'est pas loin des
adultes avec leur déviation et les
conséquences inévitables d'une sexualité
quelquefois mal apprise mal contrôlé mal
aimé